Das ist wirklich eine mittelschwere Katastrophe.
Schon wieder zeigt sich wie sorglos die Behörden in Deutschland mit Wahlen umgehen.
Die Software, mit der die meisten
Wahlergebnisse an die Landeswahlleiter übermittelt werden, die ist total
unsicher und jetzt auch noch mit einfachsten Mitteln gehackt worden
und ich muss sagen das Ganze fühlt sich für mich an wie eine
Wiederholungstat wie ein déjà vu, dabei hätte man
aus dem Debakel mit den Wahlcomputern lernen können.
Inzwischen sind sie durch das Bundesverfassungsgericht
verboten worden und das dürfte wahrscheinlich auch jetzt die Konsequenz sein.
Was jetzt passiert und warum die
Bundestagswahl die gefahr ist;
Jetzt in Clixoom Science & Fiction. Herzlich Willkommen.
Ja es war der Skandal 2008.
Bei der Landtagswahl in Hessen wurden Wahlcomputer eingesetzt die ganz einfach zu manipulieren
waren. Der Umgang mit ihnen war nämlich unglaublich
sorglos. Die Wahlcomputer wurden in der Nacht vor der Wahl bei
Parteipolitikern gelagert, die Papiersiegel der Geräte konnten
Fotokopiert werden und den Schlüssel für den Kasten in dem der Computer steckte, den gab es im Internet.
In wenigen Minuten konnte man
den Kasten öffnen und den Computer darin manipulieren.
Das Passwort baugleicher Geräte in den Niederlanden lautete:
"Geheim" und stand im Quellcode. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht verbot die Geräte.
Sie erfüllten nicht die Kriterien einer öffentlichen Auszählung.
Manipulationen hätten durch Wahlhelfer nicht
aufgedeckt werden können. Aber jetzt kommt es noch schlimmer.
Die Software, die in den meisten fällen für die Übermittlung der Wahlergebnisse
eingesetzt wird, ist um es deutlich zu sagen: "Crap". Absoluter
Müll. Ich glaube diese Bewertung ist wirklich nicht übertrieben.
Dabei sollte man nicht vergessen, dass die Abwicklung einer
Wahl ziemlich einfach ist.
Es ist Addition. Nicht mehr und nicht weniger, als das zählen und addieren von Stimmen.
Das wird in jedem Wahlkreis gemacht. Dann wieder auf kommunaler Ebene, und
so weiter und so fort. Bis das
Bundeswahlergebnis feststeht. Also wirklich kein Hexenwerk.
Aber selbst das kann man
so richtig verbocken, wie eine untersuchung jetzt zeigt. "Die Zeit"
berichtet aktuell über den Informatiker Martin Tschirsich, der den Wahnsinn aufgedeckt hat und der geht so:
"PC-Wahl", so heißt die Software, ist laut Hersteller das meistgenutzte
Wahlorganisationssystem in deutschen Verwaltungen.
Das Programm ist eigentlich nicht für Privatpersonen zugänglich aber
Tschirsich findet Teile der Software im Netz und zwar so: Er findet erst mal
im Netz das Passwort für den Servicebereich einer Firma die "PC-Wahl" vertreibt.
Dort kann er die
Bedienungsanleitung herunterladen. In dieser Anleitung stehen die Zugangsdaten
des internen Servicebereichs des Herstellers von "PC-Wahl". Achtung!
Nutzername: service
Kennwort: pcwkunde
What?!
Jetzt kann der Teile der Software laden und er kommt auf die erste gravierende
Sicherheitslücke. Wir hatten ja gerade festgestellt: Wahlen
sind nicht mehr, und nicht weniger, als Addition.
Es werden Stimmen addiert. Und genau das macht "PC-Wahl".
Und wie? Auch dass es ganz einfach.
Per Tabellenkalkulation. Die Tabellen, die "PC-Wahl" dabei
generiert, die sind vollkommen ungeschützt.
Niemand kann überprüfen ob sie echt oder manipuliert sind.
Es ist also das Einfachste, sie abzufangen,
zu manipulieren und weiterzuschicken.
die Landeswahlleiter würden absolut nichts bemerken.
Die nächste Bombe:
Städte und Gemeinden müssen das Programm aktualisieren.
Die Zugangsdaten dafür hat Tschirsich auch im Netz gefunden.
ftp,wahl
Theoretisch könnte er damit eine Manipulierte Version der Software dort hochladen
und die Kommunen würden sie herunterladen und einsetzen.
Das wäre der absolute Supergau!
Nächste Katastrophe: Die Software verschickt die Dateien,
aus Sicherheitsgründen, nicht über das Internet - super -
sondern über ein internes Netzwerk.
der Einwahlpunkt dafür ist allerdings in der Software einprogrammiert,
aber immerhin passwortgeschützt.
Aber was soll ich sagen auch in das hat Tschirsich, zumindest für Hessen, herausgefunden.
Es lautet, Achtung: test
Der Hessische Landeswahlleiter hat jetzt reagiert und eine Anordnung erlassen.
Die Wahlhelfer sollen auf der
öffentlichen Internetseite überprüfen ob ihre Ergebnisse korrekt
übermittelt wurden.
Wie bitte? Das Kind soll also erst in den Brunnen fallen und dann herausgezogen werden?
Entschuldigung wir sind die denn darauf?
Das wäre doch die absolute Katastrophe wenn im nachhinein Ergebnisse
korrigiert werden müssten.
Jetzt hat der Entwickler eine neue Version des Programms mit neuen Sicherheitsmechanismen versprochen.
Der Hamburger Chaos Computer Club hat sich das genau angesehen.
Fazit: Die neue Version ist
ungeeignet, die Schwachstellen zu beseitigen.
Der Bundeswahlleiter hat jetzt für den Notfall
telefonische Meldekette einrichten lassen um die Ergebnisse zuverlässig zu übermitteln.
Herzlich Willkommen in der Steinzeit!
Ich fürchte, dass der Notfall bereits eingetreten ist. In unserem
Hochtechnologieland werden wir am 24. September vielleicht etwas auf die Wahlergebnisse
warten müssen.
Ihr könnt übrigens ab sofort bei Clixoom mitmachen und werdet auch als Mitwirkende genannt.
Clixoom braucht
Untertitel, damit auch Menschen in anderen Ländern die Videos anschauen können.
Ihr könnt Untertitel in jeder Sprache machen zu der Ihr lust hab.
Ich freue mich über eure Mitarbeit.
Hier, bei Clixoom halte ich euch natürlich auf dem Laufenden.
Zu diesem Thema auch in den Kommentaren.
Wenn ihr kein Video zum Thema und auch zu allen anderen Themen verpassen wollt,
dann drückt mir hier ein Abo aufs Auge
und vergesst nicht den *Dong*
Auf die Glocke.
Hier geht es weiter mit: Bedroht künstliche Intelligenz die Menschheit.
Oh man,
im Moment müsste es allerdings heißen: Bedroht die Menschliche Intelligenz oder
Dummheit, vielmehr, die Menschheit. ansonsten bis dann
Bleibt dran und vor allem geht wählen!